quel est le différentiel à supposer que
une entreprise si l'irlande continuent à
taxer à nous et demi pour cent et que
cette taxe existe à 15% et bien le pays
d'origine récupérera ses deux ennemis
mais en fait quelle est l'idée là dessus
c'est que quel serait l'intérêt
admettons aussi je prends facebook qui
on va dire de d'optimiser le fisc
allemand ses bénéfices en mettant en
irlande alors que de toute façon elle
irait il conviendrait d'aller vers les
états unis où dans d'autres pays
mais l'idée est que il ya une
récupération du pays d'origine on va
dire de on va dire de nature de
l'origine du p de la société ou de la
firme taxer et donc bien sûr on y
retrouve
mais au-delà de ces différentiels c'est
qu'on veut gommer l'ensemble des paradis
fiscaux comme on le voit officiellement
comme diamants mais également on peut
voir l'irlande on peut voir singapour
vers d'autres choses et là aussi c'est
ça qu'il faut bien voir c'est qu'à terme
on risque d'avoir une âme ortiz à sion
une pendant un amortissement de tout
cesser ces paradis fiscaux il
reviendrait à la discussion de 2007 en
disant oui eh bien finalement l'ensemble
des paradis fiscaux on aura un
traitement égalitaire et les paradis
fiscaux nombreux ait plus aucun intérêt
pour ces firmes
[Musique]